hello welcome it's just past 10 GMT We
Begin this NewsHour with exclusive
coverage from a heavy militarized Zone
on the border between Tunisia and Libya
1200 migrants including pregnant women
and 29 children are stranded there with
little food water or shelter all were
rounded up in Tunisia and bus to the
Border but Libyan border guards are
refusing to let them in the foreign
ministries of both countries have
discussed what they call the irregular
migration
Human Rights Watch accuses Tunisia of
violating international law by
Collective expulsions of black migrants
mostly from sub-Saharan Africa and says
they need immediate humanitarian Aid our
reporter Malik trainer is the only
journalist there and has been speaking
to some of those stranded
can you tell me did you come from
who brought you here who brought you
here the Tunisian and what what is it
you want what is it you want
almost six days have you had have you
had water have you had food we don't
have water we don't have limited we
don't have nothing right now
what I will drink yesterday as you can
as you can see we're we're here on the
Libyan and Tunisian border and where
these hundreds of migrants and refugees
were brought here by Tunisian
authorities what they're telling us and
you can see the condition is dire we
have people there are people here that
are injured that our entire needs that
are desperate for some kind of help
we're seeing women and children they
want to feel safe they want a safe haven
what happens when you try to go back to
Tunisia what happened
some some of them they are food was
broke their business almost three people
there broke their legs
to them
yeah they take us out with their boys
some of them are saying they've been
here for six days others for a little
bit shorter but we can see if they're
injured people are injured women and
children are the situation is desperate
there needs to be some sort of a
solution to this to this crisis now
libyans will say that they're already
dealing with with a migrant migration
problem they're over according to the UN
there are over 700 000 migrants in Libya
some people are telling us that they
want to be deported back to their
country others that they want to go to
Europe but these people here the
situation
is desperate Alex Reyna on the Libya
Indonesian border
well we can speak now live to Malik
trainer he is live from the city of
zawara which is about 30 kilometers from
the Libyan border with Tunisia
extraordinary interviews there you're
one of the few journalists who've had
this sort of access to this group of
African migrants tell us a bit about
where you were and the conditions these
people were in
well we were on the coast in between
Libya and Tunisia uh when the Libyan
authorities uh took us there they
allowed these these migrants uh and and
refugees to sort of come towards the
Libyan border literally I mean we were a
meter in between the two countries you
know if a few steps uh to the towards
the migrants we would be in Tunisian uh
territory and they weren't allowed to to
reach to reach us uh border border
officers weren't allowing them uh into
the into living territory but I mean
really it was just
this their situation they're they're
just so desperate uh in need of dire
humanitarian assistance it's extremely
hot I mean right now it's about 40
degrees uh it's humid it's hot uh I
literally just standing out here for
about 20 or 30 minutes I've had to drink
uh three or four bottles of water so if
you could just imagine I mean these
people have gone days without any kind
of water without any food there are
injured people that are injured that are
in need of medical assistance now but uh
you know the authorities on both sides
uh don't seem like they they want to
help you know people told us that some
well-wishers from the Libyan side were
able to bring them enough water but I
can't see how it was enough
so your understanding is that they are
still in the same spot that you left
them in a a place described as No Man's
Land by many many of them injured with
no access to health care no access to
water no access to food they are just
stranded there
they're stranded absolutely we spoke to
a few a few uh officers at the border uh
just just about an hour ago and they
said the situation is the same if not
worse they believe more people have been
uh brought in by the Tunisian
authorities
yeah and look there were children there
there were pregnant women I mean
something needs to be done there needs
to be some sort of a solution at least
let organizations humanitarian
organizations perhaps the UN open up
some kind of corridor to bring in
assistance
the libyans will tell you that this is
not our problem this these people were
in Tunisia the tunisians are the one uh
that are that are responsible for this
situation bringing them onto the border
and expecting Libya to to bring them in
and they'll say that Libya like any
other state has the right to refuse
entry to people without legal
documentation or or or passports or
visas that can enter their territory uh
so I mean the situation is desperate
really desperate uh for these for these
hundreds uh and and now we're hearing
numbers of at least 1 200 people so the
situations is really desperate and Malik
just briefly we are hearing that these
are specifically black African migrants
that have been rounded up in Tunisia is
that is that correct
that is absolutely correct and and that
follows the insightful comments uh that
the president Christ Saeed and Tunisia
has has has has uh put out to the people
making people angry of their of their
presence in Tunisia and this is what's
led to this to this incident I mean just
to tell you one thing I had a Frank
conversation with a a Libyan senior
official and he said look if if Tunisia
thinks they have a problem with with
African migrants and refugees ours is
much worse there are more than 700 000
uh African migrants or and refugees in
Libya he said if we if we didn't care
about people we could literally in the
next couple of days put tens of
thousands of people on the border and
and and and make this a huge crisis uh
so I mean look at the end of the day
it's these people that need help right
away and a solution needs to be done as
soon as possible okay Malik thank you
for your reporting Malik trainer there
joining us from the city of zawara about
30 kilometers from the Libyan border
with Tunisia where these people have
become stranded well just to give you a
bit of context to all this earlier in
the year and we heard our correspondent
Malik refer to a president kaisaid
appeared to blame migrants for a change
of democrat demographics in the country
the Undeclared goal of these successive
waves of illegal immigration is to
consider Tunisia a purely African
country that has no affiliation to the
Arab and Islamic Nations well human
rights groups condemn those comments
call them racists now many African
migrants say they fear for their safety
tension worsened after the killing of a
Tunisian man in swax on Monday residents
demanded the expulsion of migrants from
the city
let's speak now to ameen snoozy he's a
journalist and political analyst he
joins us now from Tunis firstly I want
to ask you Collective expulsions like
we're hearing about here of these black
African migrants they're a violation
aren't they of international law
yes uh hello
um Collective expulsions are definitely
a violation of international law and
basic principle of Justice you cannot
collectively uh judge the people
um for without giving them proper rights
to uh to Legal Assistance to uh to end
to to ngos to um it's really an action
um that is permitted only because
um they are in a difficult situation and
the the uh the officials just exploited
the fact that Stacks was
um almost rioting after the crime you
mentioned uh that happened on Monday and
they exploited this anger
um in order to to evict uh migrants
without giving them proper assistance a
victim and dump them Miles and Miles
Away on a border where they have no
access to Food Water medicines and so on
it's incredibly
yes it is incredibly cruel in horrible
conditions yesterday we've actually saw
a video
um online of a woman giving birth in
those horrible conditions
um we have seen uh reports of people
drinking
um seawater we have seen a horrible
conditions on human conditions but it
doesn't seem to to to the government
doesn't seem to care as they keep
sending people there
um I don't think it is possible uh to do
something that can interest the
government it needs to be ngos and
International
International groups needs to needs to
be the one that uh that intervene and
needs to be
um needs to be strong enough to come
then what is happening right now we need
to hear more from Europe we need to hear
more from the U.N we need to hear more
from ngos in Tunisia because besides
um some of some of Human Rights Swatch
and and some other International ngos
the national Tunisian ngos are not
talking enough are not present enough to
to understand what is happening okay
well can you tell me a little bit more
about this tension that has been
increasing in recent months between
locals and the migrants more
specifically black migrants uh from
elsewhere in Africa in Tunisia I mean
what is what what is it called what has
caused it to spiral to this level
well um it's interesting because
um spax has all has always been a place
where migrants and tunisians lived
peacefully and when when you talk to
people from stocks they will tell you
that one year ago two years ago they
were okay with having migrants but now
they believe that every single
economical issue is caused by
immigration people believe that food
shortages bread shortages are caused by
by immigration which is which is we do
not have any data that can confirm that
and it's illogical to think that anyways
because shortages have been coming and
going in Tunisia for the last two years
but since I signed February statements
people now believe that every single
economical issue they have is caused by
immigration that's why there is a Target
on black people in Tunisia that is why
conspiracy theories have been
have been everywhere when it comes to
when it comes to migration and this what
led to a city where people were living
together with no issue two years ago now
they are unable to they are unable to
live together they're unable to see uh
just to see besides the this this
conspiracy theory and this crisis people
are blaming migrants for everything
okay thank you for your time thank you
for your analysis I mean snoozy
journalist and political analyst
speaking to us there from Tunis